okay for people who are here on the live
stream this is another episode of an
internal designer view of an upcoming
version of Wolfram language and the
topic this is actually a third meeting
that we livestream today and our last
for today um and this particular one is
about design of tree structures
representing trees for any purpose which
you might represent trees um
symbolic trees I guess I'm often
language okay let's get started here
so so I think
we thought we had a fairly final design
last time is that true yes syntax and
the question I have we called the syntax
for each of the symbol that we have and
some basic examples if you want let's go
ahead hold on one second here
well we're past shipyard new bring the
microphone a bit closer to you or maybe
push the gain you're coming very faint
at least to me yes that is better okay
where should we start looking at this
alright so the basic idea is tree
element of vertex data sub trees and
options right yes so we didn't do the
graphic design of this yet no not yet
have discussed this week with Chris so
we are starting to to look to look at
that Chris who what Oh Chris parati yes
okay
okay so what are you showing me here so
yeah here the idea is to show that in
the vertex data we have some reserved
keys so name is the one we discussed
last time so it it will say what we are
going to display in the in the node and
we used to have an option called vertex
label and we were not happy with that so
we decided to change it to a key in the
data that will affect the display so we
should take his example with name goes
to 1 plus 1 and label goes to a we see
that it's a ok now this property thing
that's an arbitrary property right you
can have an arbitrary list of I kind of
hate having these kind of reserved names
in this Association I mean I kind of if
we discuss this endlessly having a thing
called properties which then has its own
is it a sub association no we didn't
discuss that so here yes we can give any
other keys and any other for you I
understand but I don't like having I
really don't like mixing you know name
and label which it happened to be our
particular names with the other ones yes
so we could use the property goes to and
then an association we have discussed
several times the separation between
user properties building properties and
decoration properties and we have had
several alternatives it is a difficult
decision wait a second why is ok so
vertex data is of this node right yes
yes features of this node then sub trees
then options so why as name and label
why are they not an options
well vertex label used to be an option
but we wanted to change that to label in
the vertex data a name from the
beginning it was always not an option
so yes I would say that everything that
is going to affect the display should go
as an options we've enabled I should go
back to an option but then we will have
to see what will be the better name the
best name for that last time we were
dealing with a vertex label so singular
and we don't have these this symbol in
the integration we could always
introduce this new symbol yeah if we
want a curve I mean this is okay so go
ahead yeah so I'm forgetting or perhaps
I missed the previous meeting but what's
the division between vertex data and
options well no yes that does it
that's one of the issue no yes before
used to be that everything which affect
the display is in the ocean and in the
data we only had one reserved key which
was the name right and then anything
else was arbitrary user data they wanted
to associate with that node yes exactly
and there was another discussion whether
we should separate the reserved key from
the custom key so what about militate no
I mean so you know look does every tree
element have a name no you don't need to
provide one you can just type an empty
Association or Association of something
which does not contain the key name and
you won't have the name and you won't
have the Associated display hmm so you
totally need to give the name but the
second element is the subtree right the
second level is the search tree in this
correct
and so one thing we definitely want is
that at the leaves of the tree one could
do something like this right
yes 321 yes but you can't do that right
now because you have to have this crazy
association with follow dunk no so here
we have a shortcut I think it's a bit
above I don't remember but you can just
directly use a vertex name actually so
you don't need to yes this is the first
one so this this actually passed to an
association with the key name but this
is a short version as input so if the
name of the Association was itself an
association you would have to do use the
fully qualified form yes well this isn't
so crazy it I if you I mean look at this
case this is not so crazy because this
will be what people do most of the time
and most of the time
people will you know if they want to
stuff extra properties into this node it
seems okay actually um what other people
think I agree that if if it's you know
not Association is just the name I mean
does it evaluate them to an association
or is it just treated as a canonical
form it does evaluate to an association
yes so this is the first input form we
can see yeah that's gonna be well I
guess we have mostly tree access of
functions rather than people going in
raw with the expression right so that's
not such a big deal perhaps the problem
is name we could call it data everybody
clear shouldn't be data at the whole
decision you know it should be value
right as if said maybe I'm just thinking
of binary search trees but on some level
I think the main thing you stick in
there is the value and then you know and
then you might associate extra stuff
with that value okay what about the
possibility whatever it is it's name is
and then having the optional Association
of all kinds of other properties here
what about having something like this
okay so you would always have a name
then you would always have a name I mean
you could have none if you want to as
the name mm-hmm but that will be a rare
case
won't it yes I see as soon as we are
able to typeset as if there was no name
it's it's okay wait wait wait wait wait
wait in in this if you have a
sub-element if you have an intermediate
node and a tree there are two different
things
either the intermediate node has a name
in it or it doesn't if it doesn't have a
name in it it doesn't have a big blob of
yellow there so there's a certain
argument that having I mean that we
could have special values none and
automatic that corresponds to that
automatic corresponds to an empty yellow
marker and that none means absolutely
nothing well and then otherwise it's
whatever the name should be and that if
you want to put in properties you say
arrow a property Association
thoughts from people about this anybody
got comments on that it's certainly in
keeping with you know things like what's
a good example but you know we have
precedents for for things like this even
though I can't think of one but but but
I guess like a nearest right where you
look by this but return that right so I
think I think this is okay when we were
planning to have three element taking
the keys to extract things so then we
might have an asymmetry between
extracting the main value from the
secondary values
so having a single association which
says data or value goes to something
you really want to call it value I mean
I don't think it is value content even
name its I don't know tinta I don't
think it's data it might be name but
right but yeah well I personally think
I'm not sure I understand the difference
between name and label so here name was
really to echo what is done for graph so
typically if you have a graph and you
say vertex labels goes to name you will
have the name that you are that you have
given in that point there's a much
simpler point the subtree needs to say
where it's going to or doesn't no way
mate no does it or doesn't it no this is
a tree so the sub tree is just a list is
that correct
yes you can give a deist or an
association yes but the Association will
then implicitly fill in names for those
oh it pills in the names for the edges
right when you have an addition in do
you yeah okay okay so the comment I was
gonna make about the name the name isn't
in fact the name is purely a display
feature the name is not of semantic
relevance except insofar as you are
trying to address pieces of the tree
let's keep going god no I wonder Singh
it depends I think it has the same value
as a naming graph I will say the name
entry that we are using
so when you draw a vertex list of the
graph you get the name for it you get
the vertices but you get the name so
this is the same here can vertex data
contain keys that affect the display but
a weight and edge weight as options
I would think yes for those I mean I
could can imagine all kinds of
computations with trees that are
affected by those yes I this is a mess
no that's certainly the wrong way around
surely it will be property one arrow
inherited but you need also to give a
value to I see okay yes that would mean
inherit it from up above in the tree
they see bequeath that's for
genealogical trees or what no deposit
actually you want the parent to pass all
the all its property or some of these
properties to the children so I
understand I understand it's a it's an
obscure word in English to bequeath
stuff to one's descendants so to speak
it's like when you die you bequeath your
estate well Ida Lovelace had a good
quote that she wanted to bequeath to the
generations the calculus of the nervous
system
anyway irrelevant okay onward right so
so you're trying you're trying to say
something where this is automatically
this property or whatever is inherited
by all your children I am that is a
truly bizarre place to put it in my
opinion go ahead it's our your comment
yeah so well yeah my first comment is
inherited is you know as is is a value
right so it's you know property goes to
inherit it and that means look up above
in whatever structure for the value
don't think we really have them both
speeding and a force-fed inheritance
right either we have things which
automatically inherit like styles or we
have things where you need to specify
them at each level
[Music]
all right yeah so okay so this is an
interesting idea though force force
inheritance how on earth do we think
about that
anybody got an idea here
Roger
yeah Johnson yeah I'm here so you wanna
all the way down forcing inheritance
that's a good question how far does it
go
does that property exist for every tree
element every subtree or does it earlier
exist for one generation so to speak
yes yes we will need maybe to specify
the Nebu Eurasian yes sorry Chevy air
have you thought about sort of a case
where you want you know do you have a if
we could think of a case of where it it
provides something of you know that we
think that yes I understand
yep personally I I'm I'm more likely to
think I'm more likely to believe I think
both of these are kind of weird okay I
think that more plausible would be
something would be an operator that
basically takes a tree and you know
executes big bequeaths with whatever the
noun it's what I think too
you know because then we can think of
all these tree traversals as ways of
propagation and that would seem
incredibly natural to me they can be
done up down it can be you know several
other you know right so it's basically
seeding the tree it's it's some with the
triplet that's what I would expect to do
for many of the processing things is to
do the propagation according to and I
think having rich forms of propagation
well be you know not like our evaluation
propagation which is very special but
what you're saying is what one thing is
essentially a scan through the tree of
applying some function f okay yeah the
one is an infection through the tree of
taking a property that was somewhere in
the tree and spreading that property to
other parts of the tree yeah I mean
typically typically such a property you
might have some state as you hit to
right along but yeah you know you might
go from the top you know accumulate more
and more as you go down originally this
is these are both interesting things I
think they are not for version one both
inherited and the and the force you know
and the down inheritance the the
inheritance from above and inheritance
to below which is what the both which is
what these things are effectively I mean
it might be I just
could have a case where it sort of
becomes obvious that it's not let's keep
going let's look through this okay so
rules tree okay
use vertex names
yes so this was to show the alternative
way of constructing tree and this rules
tree passed through a tree element
detecting perform you will have a
treatment expression this thing here
yes wise rules tree blue that's a bad
sign
oh it seemed to work okay okay and it's
not terrible so the none of the leaves
the none for the sub trees or the leaves
right is the rectus when you have a
known you yes there is no children
because we wanted to have a case with an
empty list which is different that is
correct that it's an intermediate node
with no children as opposed to a leaf
node exactly because we want to be able
to replicate our expressionist structure
completely right okay so this one here
has an explicit tree element a one of
these sub one of the destinations for a
as an explicit tree element great how to
deal with rules trees of rule tree
options
yeah so here the initial ID was to have
the same option scruff and they will
apply to all - I would think so if you
want something more precise than make
you know then write code that makes the
explicit tree element structure yes
okay okay I think I should open all
these subtrees um I should know this one
okay there's an expression tree [ __ ] yes
so it takes an expression and construct
a tree limb and object from that so we
have a few we have we can leave three
arguments the second argument is a
structure so what will be the form of
the shape of the tree element output and
the third argument is the level to which
we go down so what is that second
argument main again the second argument
is it's a structure so by default we
have some other example yes below
structures of force
so here the the note the it I did not
our list and you can have the structure
head you can have this two two
sub-expression right and the same thing
for Association and the other structure
and here to discuss the rules one can
alternatively give customers so instead
of the strain you will explicitly give
the rule that takes elements and
transform them to a treatment expression
so any given element all elements have
to match that pattern I don't understand
the basic question is what do we
consider the triggering of a new subtree
it could be an HTML head or it could be
an entity head but we don't want to
convert into to me I know what's the
left-hand side that XYZ where did that
come from is X plus something that has X
Y Z's in it or what
so this come from extra extra that
particular expert didn't have lists in
it did it yes it's it's it's above it so
I see I see I see that I see okay fine
okay okay so do you have an example for
an XML tree or something I think it
should be below yes okay
by the way I mean at the beginning of
this meeting we discussed you know this
restructuring but I you know I think we
kind of settled this didn't we last time
and we went through this a great great
length so I don't really think we should
re yeah okay let's keep going here okay
so this is associations which label the
edges
so here this is a way to construct with
a customer this truck true okay text
rapido
okay so this is an example of another
type of data and we have built-in rules
for it so one is the head struck the
text element head and the other one is a
text image expression we are using
tooltip tubes and each well so wait a
minute so this particular thing that
structure what is that structure that
structure is a bunch of text elements
right
yes in this case indeed yes this is
rather unbeautiful this I mean we should
have some way of formatting these that's
nicer than this particular thing okay
but I understand this so this is using
text elements yes so each time we show
that we have to version we have one
version which take the air and the other
world which like the whole expression in
the in the node in the parent node so we
have this four okay text element for a
session and so on okay so the way to
think about this is the second thing
says what to put in each node yes
so for the text elements of expression
if you have tooltip if you over over one
yes so we will have the whole set
expression just I say okay alright let's
look at XML here so this is a very yes
this was a basic example because we have
the issue of exactly what you say so
what do we want to represent and here we
can end up with very large so this is a
short a very simple example but already
we can own a very large well and the
fact that we show nothing on its face is
kind of bad
yes so what would be the natural thing
to show in an XML structure like this by
the way how do we get a tree that is has
is differently arranged that is its root
is it like the top left and the tree
extends to the right and so on
d say we'd have to add each you with a
crew is own layouts an official a hotel
perhaps well but how does that I mean
don't we have that already in tree plot
and things like this yes I think it's
the option graph graph layout that is
used for that um okay but but wait I
thought we actually had a second
argument so what unfortunately two
things like tree plots that dealt with
things like that so not correct does
somebody know that yes in clip load
there is a second argument where you
can't see you know left right position
so he said the fourth one okay so we
need a thing like that here don't we we
need maybe we need to have an option
name you know tree orientation or
something in graph you also have
orientation mostly called orientation
that's just an option called orientation
no is this tree on dark roughly out I
think is what I think you need something
super here I mean I think maybe instead
of getting an entangled in graph layout
which is way more general that it's
you know let's call it tree layout or
something like that or tree layout or
tree orientation yeah okay tree layout
is probably the right thing just like we
have graph layout let's have a tree
layout and the tree layer it has some
string names and so on that correspond I
mean tree layout there's you know I mean
alternatively it's really where is the
tree root I think you know the graph
layout that we have in graph it's it's
become it needs to it's too complicated
you know but is it different between the
layout and orientation right yes so yes
it's true well we could we could put the
orientation information because the
problem is I don't think the orientation
is unambiguous because I think it
depends on for example I could imagine
top left corner I could imagine the
middle of the left but but then I think
that you the kind of things that you
described there are sort of you know
kind of unique to trees you know
definitely yes right so so having a tree
layout option as opposed to falling to
the general golf layout does seem highly
sensible because most of these are
totally irrelevant to tree layout right
right and and really when we come back
to graph like you know wanna partition
this to more user-friendly you know
kinds of things it's very general right
now but it's sort of challenging to use
right here for example layered layered
left like tops those are things that
attack you ibly so when you say to
layout goes to left that's not basic oh
right right is the reorientation of the
layout so you first need to specify the
layout on the end orientation so the
orientation is acetate to a layout now I
know so I'm this is an alighted name um
you know let's say left routed you know
or top routed but which way are we using
a layer layout the balloon layer because
three halves of a layout I mean we kind
of use the default one
because you're used to water what are
the other ones so there is a balloon
layout which is kind of what layout
balloon balloon yeah black is that you
mean from the center exactly yeah
so color fee yeah but it has a you know
it's useful it's it it has some some
other kinds of yes so so um have you
looked at any of these things with
things like a balloon layout no you can
do it well let's let's look for example
at this um
we could take your XML or something well
now we got that one okay
what happened there that by the way was
bad and we do need to change the default
size of the tree to be something
reasonable right based on the number of
nodes or some other heuristic am I
making sense and we agree when we're
doing that for graphs as well right yes
I think that the balloon will not for
this case it it's it's verbally
textually oriented balloon would make no
sense whatsoever
the teacher I'm saying I mean I mean one
one advantage of balloon is when the
calf gets bigger and you have less label
that's true you know it shows structure
very well but it's it this one you kind
of want to read you know so reading
around a circle it's not so good
okay so let's so in this case how do I
get the can I use a graph layout option
here
nope is the final thing a graph is this
thing a graph it is yes
okay so how would I do the layout I
would say graph on this again graph
layout is whatever okay this
autocomplete is totally broken as we
discovered in a previous meeting balloon
that what it should be called
a secondary you know chose what is
useful now behlul embedding nope well
something went wrong there so we have to
investigate that okay ah take laughs
what's that I think the the input is not
a cough inputting the easy Trina
volunteers okay well so how do we get
out - how would we turn that into a prop
and it should be although note that you
know you're almost surely going to be
losing some structure there yeah but
then didn't specify that balloon thing
you can see it comma
come on oh oh I see I see what after
this is down here she's coming in into
you okay there we go
cool I mean useless in this case but a
cool yeah I mean definitely useful so we
want a tree layout which will be an
option to all of these various tree
functions which will determine what the
golf imbedding should be and and you a
Chevy air you can select and pick among
them right so we curate a good set of of
such from what we already have and and
right and he said we want layered top
layer probably we want layered bottom
which you probably should also have for
graphs Charles things that grow from the
bottom right these are packing these are
packings those are audition for
embedding so if we do layered embedding
top bottom so essentially delay of
embedding will have four option four
different one this is incomprehensible
guys in case you didn't notice that I
told you it's it's challenging you know
it's it yeah okay your word is
challenging mine is incomprehensible
other well that make it clear yeah but
then they're not sort of clear enough
okay I think that it needs to be and
separated a little bit you know but it's
really it's not it's not just that it
needs some some additional its it's not
super quick thing to do okay fun but at
least severe can get heavy I can get
what he needs for sure okay and maybe
working with Charles to pick out the
ones are relevant right okay
how to type set composed heads yes the
Wiis is actually you hug each other at
work so the ID is that the first one you
have F as a head and a at the leaf and
in the second one you can see that F of
a is not actually typed a tree itself so
the question was do we want that so here
this is hack with a waste and something
but the question is do we want to
typeset a tree amount into a tree demon
node
so we will have to specify probably 11
if we have witnessed heat no boozing
note and so on we will have to specify a
level to stop typesetting at some point
that do we what do we want it at all or
for what sorry which what are we saying
we want do we want this weird thing yes
well yeah this is very weird here but we
have actually something this is less
truth this is not read for graph I'm
going to send you so I think there are
two separate things here one is whether
we allow a tree to be the content of an
of a node and then the other thing is
how do we typeset that
the first one I think we should allow it
look if you explicitly put a tree as the
content of a node then the node is going
to expand it's going to puff out to in
community you could put a whole giant
graph as you know as an element of a
node and then you would want to draw the
graph here and that's fine
now you know the question is is this
graphically the best thing to do
and that's not so clear
that reform is not able to do this under
the form of F of a of B no this
shouldn't be the default right bit okay
if I see
look the problem is that graphically
this is bad right but that's a question
of how we choose to render the nodes not
the question of whether we should have a
node within a node right I think it's
okay to have an older than I know but
not with it not with these giant yellow
wings on it yes yes this is oh this is
very bad so this is something we have
started discuss it with Chris no
realities in situ yeah okay
what name for the structure we had the
represented as nodes yeah so usually
this is this is the not an option for
instance with the level but here this is
the third expression tree evaluation
this can only apply when we are looking
at the self expression structure so the
main idea is only that it you take the
head of the sub expression and you put
it as an order as a children as a child
so this is very similar to what we have
for level so you have the level of the
hell and the level of the part of the
expression are the same and we want it
to be able to represent that in the tree
structure but the name seems very bad
set expression with head listen we've
got quite a bit of other stuff to go
over here that we are not going to
finish right now because I've got
another meeting coming up um this is
gonna need at least another hour and a
half two hours I think
how much let me just see tree objects
and graphs what's this about so this is
to truss I'm a tree into a graph and
graph into a tree right okay
other manipulations which there are
quite a few right yes so he tree rules
take the rules for Wall Street to
inserts is to insert a tree tree rules
gives the rules version of a tree like
exactly tree insert puts a subtree at a
particular position yes specified by
positional a or by an association you
know name sequence tree replace so
insert makes this be that position
basically and what does it do if it's
not contiguous so here you have an
example are you thing but the last
example for instance three fun I don't
know um maybe I mean I guess my question
is oh I see though that that's an empty
one that was put in there as a
placeholder is that correct yes well
that's a very ugly way to do it you take
the position three so it's really like
inserts so first one we take the blue in
three orders insert to insert the insert
just fails doesn't it if I say insert
into the list
ABC an X at position 10
just says it can't do it mm-hmm right it
can do it if you do it to position four
but I don't think it can do it to
position 5 no but here's the same for
transferred it would complain
what's this node thing oh that's that's
okay fine that's a puts it in to be
position 3 and to be position 5 well
this is 5 plus 1 because we have
inserted one earlier yes so this is
really how does answer to that it's the
same
yes okay fine yep yeah okay it's it's at
old position five yeah okay by the way
have you started documenting all of this
stuff you know the kids we should start
that tree replace what is this doing
this is replacing an actual node or a
sub tree is that correct yes but you
know that's gonna be messy because these
trees the canonical form of these trees
is complicated with all these
associations and things right yes this
is something that we wanted to discuss
also this other four part Channel four
trees yes
at least you avoid evaluation what so
here if you want to either tree elements
since it's going to be in the in the
rule of three place it's going to
evaluate so to do this properly it may
be better to introduce a tree portion
symbol oh gosh I mean the alternative
would be to clean this up and to make
sure that there is a that the tree
replace knows that these things will
have been canonicalized and that it can
for example treat the associations as
order lists etc etc that's what I would
do I mean I think I think having a whole
tree pattern thing right now seems
unfortunate okay tree extract
right what is three paths now so this is
a rapper to select the path for to
extract and we can have integral string
and so on depending on the query that is
performed and we have we can have a list
of three of triples or just one triples
so this is typically used to mix part
specification and extract specification
okay but um okay
so tree pattern is content of the tree
tree path is position in a tree yes this
may be another horrifying thing look
we're gonna need quite a few more hours
on this this is and look we should also
decide who in this meeting actually
needs to be here for what we're doing
and what other issues are gonna come up
because we have not discussed I mean I
don't know what's needed for for example
XML tree manipulation does anybody here
have an opinion about that
and other functions that we're providing
here adequate for XML treat manipulation
we have looked at this XPath language
which is very close to XML Neron and we
have imitated some of their appears
particular being able to go up and down
in positions and query in the process
yes I understand but that's often from a
given place in a tree I mean that's in a
in a you know procedural way of dealing
with a tree you're sitting at a
particular node and then you're doing
things but I guess if we have a node
specification then how do you apply a
function at a particular node in the
tree
what you mean on the vertex data on the
whole tree demon expression on the tree
so in other words I want to apply a
function at a particular position in a
tree and for example I might want to
look above me to find out you get what
I'm saying
too much or to apply but but you know
Stephen is really asking for like a tree
locate write like notebook locate you
you know find this element and then go
up a level which is a different from
that for a fly yeah that's possibly true
well but I also be happy to have
something where I can be a apply at this
point in the in the tree right but be
able to address in doing what I'm doing
you know make a replacement whatever
else I'm doing at that to that subtree
but in doing that look up above me Oh to
you know to see what context I need to
use and so on
am I making sense sorry but here you
only you can look you can't have a
reference to an ax
you'll you always deal with the whole
tree right you cannot have RSS to an
element and query the parent and you
well yes you can because you can have
every tree element has an address so if
you say apply this function at this tree
element position mm-hmm right yeah or
alternatively you could be mapping all
the way through the tree you could say
go to every visit every node of the tree
in it in a you know depth-first
traversal of the tree and at every
element look above at its you know
grandparents and so on if it has them
yeah we can extract all the uncles and
etc forgiven note but currently we can
not map a function on them right I
understand so we're gonna need that
we're gonna need some kind of tree I
mean what is this it's a it's a what
will be the analogous function in an
expression not that yeah Matt I mean
some kind of tree map hat but possibly
you know tree map is a more important
thing because that's the thing where you
scan a whole XML expression or something
looking for all occurrences of this
given that it's in a context of that and
so on maybe there is a cool tree fold
yeah maybe there is what would that mean
I've heard of tree fold e type things so
let's just think about that so that
means you are yeah yeah because a tree
fold will unroll itself and then re-roll
as it goes down so in other words given
a particular path through the tree the
tree fold is the thing that has
accumulated itself going down that path
right and what we could do you know is
to say how do you how do you flow
through it how do you traverse it and it
might be a very cool functional way to
package those actually because you have
a state right like in fold now you have
the things that are coming in from from
the tree depending on which path you're
taking exactly but then it rolls and
unrolls right because as to play on the
path right so that's you know I had a
parameterization I hate to always say
this kind of thing but I had a
parameterization of this type of thing
for evaluation an SMP I had two
parameters that were represented this
which were just utterly utterly
incomprehensible yeah it's not
necessarily super easy but I think you
having concrete cases to work with there
is gonna be super yeah yeah no I really
like the idea of a tree fold I think
that's very interesting and I think that
I mean tree fold well look it's clear
there's depth first breadth-first those
are two you know ordering criteria and
in general the ordering is you know in
general what you would do to define
ordering is you would say it is
something you know it is lexicographic
on the parts on the part numbers for
instance
or whatever it is right I mean our map
you know map also has never defined a
traversal order but map is essentially
depth first on the part numbers right
now clearly when you have something
where the you know tree branches are
labeled by keys in an association things
get a little bit more elaborate because
you don't just have numerical sequence
to deal with you might have some more
complicated ordering criteria which
might get even more messy but even if
you just take the numerical ones you
know depth-first corresponds to one
particular you know in other words if
you say where did you visit write
depth-first you can just put down all of
the locations where you visited and
depth-first corresponds to some kind of
lexicographic sorting breadth-first to
another kind of sorting and so on right
and so I think it's defined by that
sorting by that ordering criterion on
the locations and I don't know what I
don't know whether that's but yeah my
guess is that those two up get you a
large fry I mean look the other one is
negative levels for map where you're
coming up from the leaves of the tree
that's the other one that we've we've
had for a long time but this is an
operation we don't have in in their
expression world so perhaps this is more
like a traverse like a tree Traverse yes
and it could exists with expressions on
circuit reverse write which is which is
a
visiting expressions in some random
order right right it could also be a it
could also be a traversal order option
to map because I think it's fairly
obscure I mean in 30 years we haven't
really had a particular need for it to
be fair and and when I put something
like that into SMP it was one of the
absolutely incomprehensible features we
build it sometimes in C code when we
need it
[Music]
fair enough but I think a traversal
order option to map would be highly
interesting and I think tree fold is
highly interesting and we need to wrap
this meeting so to be continued
presumably hopefully early next week
um and looks very nice so this this code
is it going into the head branch or the
ex-con where is this code say via so we
will put this you know externally yes
okay go ahead this is basically a
prototype so we should have something
better faster than this okay
I mean how close is this to being usable
this is use a wolf whistles more small
cases that's good enough to start I
think this is gonna require some design
shakedown still I think the son is
experimental even if it only handles
comparatively small cases it's highly
worthwhile because I predict there gonna
be some things that aren't fantastic and
they um I think I think you should start
documentation on this stuff I mean this
is I have to say this whole subsystem
has been has turned out to be
unbelievably much hairier than I
expected I have to say I mean in a sense
this is almost as complicated as the
graph subsystem in many ways
um which is surprising to me but anyway
so it goes I mean by the way of course
these I mean the analog of traversal for
a graph we don't really have do we or do
we do with breadth-first scan and
depth-first scan oh yeah yeah right
which we by the way could use those
exact same functions for trees yes and
we should but they're complicated
Stephen they're they're very general but
they're complicated so I would encourage
us to try to find you know easier use
cases yes I understand cover everything
but yeah right which which might not
work for trees effort for graphs right
we probably should have the things that
work on graphs also work on trees where
the trees are treated as if graphs so to
speak right meanwhile I mean you know
graph replacement is something I really
would love to see us do but that's a
different conversation but we can you
know tree replacement is a lot easier
all right um okay all right talk chilsen
then